>> THE REASON I ANNOUNCED THIS
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS THE CORONA -- CRISIS, SO
WE CAN END THE HEAR AND NOW
ADDRESS AS WE GO FORWARD WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
STEVE: HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI LAUNCHING AN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WITH SUBPOENA POWER TO
OVERSEE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO
COVID-19.
HERE WITH REACTION IS HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
HE JOINS US FROM CAPITOL HILL.
LEADER, ISN’T THAT WHAT CONGRESS
IS SUPPOSED TO DO?
AREN’T THEY SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO THE ADMINISTRATION?
>> YES.
AND WE ARE ALL PROVIDING THAT
THINK FOR ONE MOMENT YOU HAVE
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THAT
THAT’S ALL THEY FOCUS UPON.
IN THE LAST BILL THAT WE JUST
PASSED THE CARES ACT WE CREATED
THREE NEW OVERSIGHT ENTITIES,
RIGHT IN THE PANDEMIC OVERSIGHT,
THAT IS A SET-UP OF INSPECTOR
GENERALS GWINN FINE IS RUNNING
THAT INDIVIDUAL APPOINTED BY THE
PRESIDENT, CONFIRMED BY THE
SENATE AND ACTUALLY CREATED A
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT IS THAT
IS APPOINTED BY ALL THE LEADERS
FROM SCHUMER TO McCONNELL TO
PELOSI AND MYSELF.
IS REDUNDANT.
BUT WHAT’S MOST TELLING HERE IS
WHO SHE APPOINTED.
SHE DIDN’T GO WITH THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIR, HER OWN.
SHE APPOINTED CLYBURN.
REMEMBER WHAT CLYBURN SAID THAT
HER MAJORITY WHIP.
HE SAID THIS IS THE TIME TO
RESTRUCTURE INTO THEIR VISION
GOVERNMENT.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT OVERSIGHT.
SOUNDS LIKE PURE POLITICS.
REALLY THE SPEAKER SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON WHAT WE NEED TO
DELIVER TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
LET’S TAKE CARE OF THE CRISIS AT
HAND RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT
OVERSIGHTS ALREADY LOOKING AT
THIS.
AND THIS IS WHAT SHE COMES UP
WITH?
WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE
JUST SAID THAT WE PASSED.
LET’S GET IT TO SMALL BUSINESS.
LET’S GET PEOPLE CONTINUING TO
WORK.
LET’S MAKE SURE WE GET THAT
140 BILLION OUT TO THE HOSPITALS
WHO ACTUALLY NEED IT.
OUR MODERN DAY SOLDIERS IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
STEVE: YEAH.
YOU KNOW, IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS,
INCLUDING SPEAKER PELOSI WHO IS
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT PHASE 4.
WE HAVE JUST GOTTEN PHASE 3
STARTED RIGHT NOW.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO SOME OF
HER -- SOME OF HER AGENDA ITEMS
REGARDING PHASE 4.
IT DOES SOUND LIKE IT’S A LOT OF
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS PROPOSED IN
JANUARY.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS NOW THEY
HAVE ADDED MONEY FOR HOSPITALS
AND COMMUNITY CLINICS.
RIGHT?
>> WHAT SHE IS PROPOSING IS THE
THINGS SHE WAS DENIED IN THE
LAST BILL.
THINGS THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH CORONAVIRUS.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
CHANGING ELECTION LAW.
BAILING OUT STATES ON PENSIONS
THAT WERE SPENT INCORRECTLY.
PROVIDING MORE MONEY TO
SANCTUARY CITIES.
EVERYTHING THAT DOESN’T DEAL
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS, PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, THESE ARE THE THINGS
THAT WHY SHE HELD THIS BILL UP
FOR MORE THAN FOUR DAYS.
I MEAN, ALREADY BE IMPLEMENTED
TODAY.
WE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
ARE GETTING THE MONEY OUT HAD
SHE NOT HELD THE BILL UP
EARLIER.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, SINCE PHASE 3
IS NOW UNDERWAY AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
WIND UP GETTING CHECKS AS EARLY
AS NEXT WEEK.
AS A FORMER SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
YOURSELF, YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU
STARTED A BUSINESS WHEN YOU ARE
ABOUT 20 YEARS OLD, HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE FINDING THESE TIMES SO
CHALLENGING WITH THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS THAT THEY GET ON THE
WEBSITE AND START THE PROCESS OF
GETTING THE MONEY THAT IS OUT
THERE FOR THEM TODAY?
>> THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING TO DO.
THIS BILL DOES A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
WHAT IT DOES WITH SMALL BUSINESS
IS IMPORTANT.
IF YOU ARE A SOLE PROPRIETOR.
A SMALL BUSINESS WHERE I WAS
WHEN I WAS 20 YEARS OLD.
GOVERNMENT HAS SHUT YOU DOWN TO
MOST OF THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES
SO YOU HAVE NO INCOME.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE YOU
LIQUIDITY.
IT’S ONLY A TWO PAGE FORM THAT
YOU HAVE TO FILL OUT.
IT’S OUT THERE.
GO TO MY TWITTER PAGE, I WILL
HAVE IT UP THERE.
GOP LEADER TO BE ABLE TO SEND IT
TO YOU.
WHAT DO IS PAY YOUR EMPLOYEE HE
IS AND PAY YOUR RENT AND PAY
YOUR UTILITIES, THAT’S NO LONGER
A LOAN.
A PORTION OF THAT IS A GRANT.
WE WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE WORKING.
WE WANT TO SUPPLY YOU THE
RESOURCE.
IF YOU ARE A LARGER BUSINESS WE
WILL SECURE A LOAN AND GIVE YOU
RETENTION TAX CREDIT TO PAY FOR
HALF OF YOUR EMPLOYEES.
INDIVIDUALS WILL GET A CHECK
DIRECTLY TO THEM IF THEY ARE
MAKING $99,000 OR LESS AND
HOSPITALS GET RESOURCES THAT’S
WHAT THE CARES ACT DID.
THAT’S WHAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING INSTEAD OF LOOKING
AT SOME OTHER BILL OR SOME OTHER
OVERSIGHT WE JUST INSTATUED
THREE NEW OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES
TO OVERSEE THIS.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF OVERSIGHT
SPOKESMAN SAID THIS BIPARTISAN
COMMITTEE’S WORK WILL HELP SAVE
LIVES AND TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN
REALTIME NOT AFTER IT’S TOO LATE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND THAT’S
SOMETHING EVERYONE SHOULD
WELCOME.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> THAT’S JUST NOT TRUE.
HALLS SHE NOT LEARNED FROM THE
IMPEACHMENT AND MAYBE THAT’S
WHAT SHE IS THINKING ABOUT HERE.
YOU CANNOT CREATE A NEW SELECT
COMMITTEE WITHOUT CONGRESS
VOTING.
I’M HERE BECAUSE I’M MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT TODAY.
BUT NOBODY IS HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
WHEN WILL WE COME BACK AND VOTE
ON THIS?
IT WOULD BE TOO LATE.
THAT’S WHY IN THE CARES ACT WE
IMPLEMENTED THREE NEW OVERSIGHT
ENTITIES WITHIN THERE THAT SHE
HAS AN APPOINTMENT.
TO SAY BUT WE ALREADY HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ONLY TO
FOCUS ON THIS AND WE ALSO HAVE
EVERY SINGLE COMMITTEE HAS AN
OVERSIGHT SUBCOMMITTEE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THIS IS JUST
POLITICS AS USUAL INSTEAD OF
FOCUSED ON THE CRISIS THAT WE
NEED TO BE TODAY DELIVERING FOR
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
MAKING SURE WE ARE GETTING THE
RESOURCES TO THEM.
STEVE: WELL, KEVIN McCARTHY
STANDING ALONE ON CAPITOL HILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.